- (together) Charlie,
Charlie, are we safe?
(screaming)
- So after a brief investigation,
we've decided that this
Charlie Charlie thing is
kinda just an internet hoax.
- (together) Charlie,
Charlie, are you there?
Charlie, Charlie, are you there?
Charlie, Charlie, are you here?
- Charlie, Charlie, are
you in a chocolate factory?
- So for the duration of this video,
I'm just gonna mess with people.
- Man, I don't mess with ghosts.
- I am so superstitious, I
don't know why I'm doing this!
- Don't know if I can set this,
my nerves are a little,
I'm a little shaky.
- You're shaking.
- I know, it's terrifying.
I'm a little shaky.
- (together) Charlie,
Charlie, can we play?
(screaming)
- No? (scared noises)
- Charlie's here, Charlie
is in the building.
- It ain't Charlie, it's somebody else.
Grandma?
- I do not wanna die with
you, man, no offence.
- (together) Charlie,
Charlie, do you wanna hurt us?
- No! (screaming)
- Oh my god!
- I think I'm done.
- (together) Charlie,
Charlie, can we play?
(laughing)
- [Voiceover] Alright,
Charlie, you can come out now.
- No, no, no, no, no.
No, stop!
If this is a thing, you need to stop it!
What are you doing?
- I'm Charlie.
- Why are you doing that?
What?
- Shut up!
Shut up!
Oh, I hate you so much!
(laughing)
- Why, why, why?
- Charlie, Charlie, will you appear?
- What?
- I'm Charlie.
- Hi.
- No, I'm not possessed!
- Oh my god!
(laughing)
- It's bringing millions and
millions of people together so
I guess there's some benefit to all this.
All connecting over a Mexican demon.
- So, thank you, Charlie.
Oh and just for safety's sake,
goodbye, Charlie.
- Charlie, Charlie, will
me and my bae work out?
Oh no! (laughing)
Oh damn, sorry, babe.